the Joe Rogan experience in our and the
other thing Rick rastas he owns like a
hundred Buffalo Wild Wings Buffalo stops
wing Stein's 2-shot the wing stops
Christie stops that's a good move right
people always want wings wings have been
around forever do I [ __ ] my mouth my
lovely loved ones they used to be a
place right outside Boston comedy in the
village we do sets at Boston comedy and
there's this winged spot and they had
there are different levels and one was
suicide
this you would get this suicide sauce on
this [ __ ] on these wings all Mike
purple like it was the purpose I didn't
know at the time I didn't understand hot
peppers but it was definitely habanero
because it was an orange color huh like
a real orange color and you would eat
those wings and just be like gee it's
like a weird combination of pleasure and
pain takes your breath away your lips go
white ah
I [ __ ] love wings yeah I don't want
to do that wings show though
so I've done a good way to talk man you
know it's like interesting you do well
it'd be fun though justice it'd be fun
to see you on I know but why are you
asking people personal questions whether
crime what's hot as [ __ ] some guys just
like some guys just crush it where there
doesn't phase I'm like how does that
happen
oh there's my friend Tommy Hirsch go
I've talked about him before we used to
be a place called chili my soul in
Encino and it was just crazy chili place
this guy was into the most ridiculously
hot chili it was so hot you would have
to like sign a waiver if you wanted to
buy the stuff that they put in it and
they would you say he was telling me
that even with that the hottest [ __ ]
that they had they had like a number
system I think I think ten you know I
think I ate was like the most I could
tolerate but they would have these guys
from Nepal come and even with the ten
number ten the hottest [ __ ] they had
these dudes be putting some extra hot
sauce holy [ __ ]
do you like spicy Stein no I don't like
it that spicy I like can't hand by sea
but I like spicy I like I love jalapenos
with elk it's like my favorite color yes
I slice up like four or five jalapenos
and I'm in the bunch of slices every
time I take a piece of elk I put a piece
of jalapeno on that [ __ ] right now
when you post it I might fall asleep in
the cheese pizza my god damn dude stuff
keeps you alive
[Applause]